for you uh I feel like San Francisco and
the bay and Oakland were
probably as heavily impacted by the
pandemic as like a lot of cities because
you know with extreme wealth comes with
extreme poverty
um
when I go to the Bay because I I try to
make it out there probably like four or
five times a year
for Empire [__] and um it feels like
like at least in the city it feels like
a lot of energy has kind of gotten
pulled out of it now every time I go
everyone's like it's Oakland is where
you want to be Oakland's where you know
the nightlife is still thriving and you
know for you being somebody from Oakland
and just kind of assessing like the
state of the bay as a city as a as a
metropolitan area rather
um how do you feel like you feel like
it's bouncing back at all
or because because I you know I was at
um trying to go to a [__] Walgreens
in San Francisco and that [__] was just
not open because of the the you know
everyone was stealing [__] out of there
it's tough man yeah um
and before we address the secondary we
must address the primary you know we're
in a the economical deficit is
definitely has infected and impacted
right um and most of the times when this
happens uh you hear the wealthy complain
about the loss of their wages and riches
and things of their businesses that are
slowing down but the flip side to that
is what about those that don't have
those businesses to be affected right so
if poverty imagine how they're affected
so if poverty if the wealthy are being
affected imagine how impactful and
affected people who are living in
poverty but poverty and so what that
does is that induces all of the other
things crime goes up
you know the violence uh and the
impoverished mindset right so in that
mind State you look at a lot of the
people that are involved that are trying
to rise above their areas that they're
coming from it's it's it becomes crucial
man it becomes uh
it's a sad state right you know it's a
sad state where I can't come visit you
at your store because I'm worried about
if my windows are going to get broken
into right I can't come uh patronize
your nightclub because I don't know if
I'm going to get robbed going leaving my
club you know I'm saying leaving the
club so that's the the climbing and the
sending it uh the sentiments that we
that we deal with and we have to factor
into these equations but you can't blame
them for doing what they're doing out of
an active survival yeah I mean that's
and that's that's the other the other
side of the coin like the law of I think
it's you could steal under a thousand
dollars like if you have no money
and you're starving
and you could go
get your food and get your whatever you
need and nothing gonna happen to you I
mean you're gonna do it or not you know
what I mean you're gonna we we have to
stop being so judgmental and judging
right or wrong in situations that's
either starve yeah it's like context to
every situation like you know what I'm
saying and and there's people who are
going to take advantage of that who
might not be starving yeah most
definitely most definitely you know um
it's hard to not be empathetic but then
it's also understanding that you know I
don't I don't want to be
naive to the situations that's going on
so
yeah like I say you know I there is is
what it is man and you just you just
hope you know keep your fingers crossed
and hope that you and your family are
protected man and that people find their
way
um and then as someone like myself as an
influencer continue to keep leading by
example to show people how to create
your own Wills right and you know and
creating creating those Wills you can uh
quench The Thirst of many in your
village I saw was it your daughter whose
car got bit her uh her mother okay yes I
saw like what you posted was it her
schoolwork that got her schoolwork yeah
and you were like hey I get it as part
of the game I get it but can I get my
daughter's backpack back get it like
like people
love the game
until the rules
hit them and now they want to change the
rules right bro we in it we know what we
signed up for we know where we live in
we know you know you can't change the
law of the Jungle right right right
right you know what I mean and we
understand that and no one is is immune
to being affected by you're not above it
like you're you're not above now I don't
care what you're doing if you if you in
this you know what it is it's just like
if you're in the game and you signed up
for something you got to come even when
it ain't in your favor so as I say you
know my my uh
my public service announcement you know
to the bippers out there like hey man
hey if you guys you guys hit this car
yeah I didn't know if you got the bag
man ain't nothing in there but some
homework I need it yeah that's it and so
um it has worked before
um it didn't work that time right it has
worked before
um
the relationship you know some of the
guys you know these young guys
um they're the they're the mass
Crusaders so sometimes you may know him
and don't even know that you know him
and that's true and they'll follow you
like oh man my bad I didn't know and you
know come drop it off but uh man my
daughter is such a warrior man she was
able to steal Ace all of her finals and
everything
um Straight A's to wait till it was like
her homework her notes it was her notes
oh her notes and it was a week before
finals you know yeah and uh she's she's
uh she's a champ for sure she's such a
champ man and she's like she's she is so
devoted to school man um and getting
into uh she wants to go
um
to you know like an MIT or things like
that so she's she's super dedicated
still aced her finals Straight A's man
and I'm proud of her